[Music]
Southwestern BC brought to a snowy
standstill this Wednesday night the
winter white out the treacherous roads
20 20 stuck buses and the grounded
flights a crisis in the cold we have in
fact been at an over capacity the
struggle to keep the unhoused safe and
warm the information war in Israel and
Gaza there were LS yes but who killed
them I'm not sure conflicting narratives
as both sides try to influence public
opinion and from the palace to the
hospital the surgeries for two members
of the royal
family global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us the winter season that seemed
a little late to arrive is now
impossible to ignore millions of
Canadians are under some form of winter
weather warning tonight and BC's South
Coast has been blanketed with heavy
snow the wheels were spinning on Hills
across Metro Vancouver some commuters
jumped into action to help their fellow
drivers and all the snow is causing
delays at Vancouver's airport which says
it was operating at 80% capacity today
in central Canada extreme cold is the
concern in parts of Southern Ontario
windchill values are making it feel like
minus 30 raising concerns about how the
most vulnerable are coping as warming
centers and shelter spaces quickly fill
up we'll have more on that in a moment
but we begin tonight in BC where there's
a potential for snowfall records to be
broken n Gara begins our
coverage even for those most prepared I
have a winter tire so it's not it's not
bad driving here winter weather alerts
blanketing Southern BC usually mean
seeing SES like
[Music]
this I got Snow's on tried turning and
now I'm
stuck is this winter tires just too icy
yes too icy yeah as of the morning
commute traffic was snarled on major
routes across Metro Vancouver stay home
if you can last year I got stuck for 13
hours that's why this year I'm planning
to go in the bus but many of the
Region's buses are no match for these
conditions my bus got delayed and then
the one that came and got stuck so I
couldn't get to work I'm happy they
canceled I'm on my way home right now
hey
that this bus driver borrowing a good
Samaritan's shovel a tool this family is
using hey for a snow day as schools and
universities across the province's South
Coast closed saw a lot of cars on the
ditch s me getting pulled out and I'm
like no this isn't worth it turned
around came home and here I am spending
a snow day with the kids I right k Mak
it a snow bad as the storm knocked out
power to thousands of customers in the
province's southwest corner
municipalities opened extra warming
centers at Vancouver International
Airport more than 30 morning flights
were cancelled officials say the steady
flow of heavy snow is keeping them on
their toes just being able to keep up
with the clearing of the snow and the
ice from our runways some cities have
closed access to the most treacherous
roads as workers on the Region's Bridges
clear cables you got to if I fall be
safe there's always those who get around
however they
can and those who can't help but to
embrace the elements we instead of
shoveling we just started rolling a ball
and this is what came out of it
especially as the province is advising
people to just stay home if they can
with the threat of freezing rain
overnight nugara Global News Vancouver
on Vancouver Island nearly 20,000 people
woke up without power this morning after
the storm hit there Kylie Stanton is
outside the BC legislature in Victoria
Kylie yeah Donna I think most of us in
Greater Victoria woke up thinking we may
have missed the brunt of this storm
there was really just a light dusting
early on but things quickly changed the
snow started to come down heavily
prompting the majority of school
districts across Vancouver Island to
close and up on the malahat a Mountain
Highway pass commercial vehicle chain up
rules are being strictly enforced road
crews worked through the night clearing
the route trying to stay on top of the
snowfall drive to the condition of the
road be prepared um I would say that if
you just give the plow trucks lots of
room let them do their job they'll let
you buy when they can and please don't
pass them on the right now as you can
see the snow has stopped here in
Victoria's Inner Harbor but the
temperatures are expected to hover
around the freezing Mark so we will be
keeping an eye on what's to come Donna
okay Kylie Stanton and Victoria thanks
and with a wider look at conditions
across BC and what's forecast Global
News meteorologist Christy Gordon joins
me Christy what's in store Donna this
was really a substantial snowstorm
across Southern BC particularly the
South Coast Area the reason is it was
two systems that combined one from the
north that held in that Arctic carac
crossa region combining with a Pacific
system which brought in that moisture so
at YVR we actually saw the second
highest snowfall amounts for the month
of January at 23 cm of snow but look at
chilak 38 cm of snow and in areas like
chilak we also saw windy conditions with
GSS up to 60 km an hour so it was white
out conditions there snow still possible
through the latter part of the day but
generally this will shift out overnight
we're keeping our eye on this next
system which is going to drive onshore
bringing in the potential for more snow
for Metro Vancouver a risk of freezing
rain also although because of the delay
there's a chance it may transition to
rain by the time it moves in keeping our
fingers crossed in the meantime the
biggest concern will be any of the Melt
that we saw today will refreeze
overnight it will be very icy tonight
and tomorrow morning after what was a
record-breaking mild December it is
definitely feeling like winter as is the
case across much of the country Donna
back to you sure is Global News
meteorologist Christy Gordon thank you
after a mile December the mercury has
plunged in Southern Ontario people in
the Toronto area woke up to temperatures
that felt close
to-30 while some are enjoying the blast
of Winter the cold is putting those who
are vulnerable and unhoused at even more
risk Mike Dray
reports crisp sound of skate blades on
Fresh ice is music to the ears of karuna
valino bitter cold be damned I had to
put on like three layers of everything
because yeah I don't do well in the cold
but it's the perfect time for skating
winter despite its late start has made
Ottawa feel a bit more like Ottawa for
the past week this feels more like
normal Toronto however the cold snap has
exposed a growing crisis with 11,000
people in its shelter system the city
has faced massive pressure to keep
everyone warm and safe we are not
turning anyone away it's City policy
that even when we're at capacity the
doors remain open the system may be
bending but Toronto is determined to see
that it doesn't break as of this weekend
this is the first time that we have in
fact been at an over capacity from our
Winter's program point of view Wednesday
was the coldest day of what has so far
been the coldest week of winter but
relief is on its way a lot of folks
taking the the cold air had arrived it's
going to stay here for a while it
certainly has lasted for a number of
days in in parts of the country but it
does look like an overall trend to back
to milder than normal conditions again
especially in Southern Ontario uh by uh
early next week and that warm weather
could last until the end of
January ski Hills that look downright
miserable just a few weeks ago have for
the most part recovered but how long
will that
last and back in Ottawa the national
capital commission reports it's working
diligently to prepare the r Canal for
skaters after it remained closed last
winter but doubt Rises with the
temperature Mike trle Global News
Toronto who the same storm system
hitting British Columbia is causing
freezing rain in parts of Oregon and
Washington State authorities there are
warning people to stay off the roads
more than 15,000 flights have been
delayed or cancelled across the us over
the past couple of days at least 14
deaths are blamed on the cold the winter
conditions stretch all the way to the
south in Tennessee these boat shelters
have collapsed under the weight of the
snow the US has redesignated Yemen's
houthi Rebel group a terrorist
organization a response to repeated
attacks on commercial ships in the Red
Sea which the US says fit the the
textbook definition of terrorism the US
says the designation will impede funding
to the houthis who were backed by Iran
the houthis though say it will not stop
their attacks aimed at forcing Israel to
end its Siege of Gaza in Yemen
University students displayed their
anger carrying Palestinian flags and
shouting anti-American slogans the US
and UK backed by other countries
including Canada have launched a wave of
air strikes against dozens of houi
Targets in Yemen Pakistan has recalled
its ambassador to Iran a day after tan
launched air strikes on Pakistan Iran's
foreign minister says drones and
missiles targeted a militant group in
Pakistan which he described as an
Iranian terrorist group Pakistan has
denounced the attack as an unprovoked
violation of its airspace and warned
there could be serious consequences two
children were killed China has urged
Iran and Pakistan to exercise restraint
after the deadly strike people in
southern Gaza say last night was one of
the most intense bombardments since the
start of Israel's war on
Hamas at least seven people were killed
in Han Yunis ambulances rushed the
injured to Nasser hospital as bombing
and gunfire rang out across the city and
Israeli tanks have approached the area
overnight a shipment of medicine for
dozens of hostages held by Hamas has now
arrived in
Gaza it's unclear if the supplies have
been distributed yet cter and France
helped arrange the delivery of 50 5
metric tons of Aid in exchange for more
humanitarian supplies for Palestinians
it is the first deal brokered between
Israel and Hamas since November's brief
pause in fighting two Royals and two
surgeries coming up the separate health
condition sending Princess Kate and King
Charles to the
hospital we are learning more about the
deadly stabbing of a woman outside a
Calgary Elementary School police
described what happened as domestic in
nature the Killer is the woman's
estranged husband who was found dead
nearby he had previously been charged
with sexual assault as Tracy Nagi
reports The Killing has left the
community shaken and is highlighting the
need for more resources and awareness of
domestic violence flowers lay outside a
Calgary Elementary School a day after a
mother was brutally murdered the victim
of a domestic homicide this was a very
traumatic event that occurred in a
public Place investigators say officers
were called to the area just before 8
Tuesday morning to find a woman dead the
elementary school and a preschool were
both put on lockdown as anxious parents
arrived with little information well I
got a phone call from her kindergarten
teacher uh saying that there's been an
accident at school uh they're closing
and they need us to come and get the
kids right away the suspect the woman's
estranged husband was found dead in a
nearby park a short time later Global
News has now learned a publication ban
is an effect on the identity of the
victim in relation to previous charges
showing the man was charged with sexual
assault in
2023 the man was also facing charges for
violating a no contact order in
September and again in November this is
a family that was known to us this is a
local family that police have responded
to and had interactions with uh a number
of times um so we'll obviously be
looking at all of uh our previous
interactions uh to see um you know what
uh what was done and what could have
been done different if anything
according to data from statistics Canada
almost 8 in 10 victims of intimate
partner violence are women and girls an
intimate partner violence has been on
the rise since 2014 the Alberta Council
of women shelters shows domestic
violence is at a decade high in Alberta
between 2022 and 2023 more than 11,000
women and seniors were unable to find
safe space at shelters due to a lack of
space I believe it's related to the
complexity of the financial realities
we're dealing with in the community the
aftermath of you know our health
precautions and and the pandemic
situation uh but we are seeing a trend
that continues to go up the school
reopened on Wednesday officials say a
support team has been brought in to help
students and staff Tres NY Global News
Calgary the high-profile defense lawyer
representing convicted sex offender
Peter nyard has withdrawn from the case
at a hearing in Toronto where a
sentencing d for niggard was to be set
lawyer Brian Greenspan told the judge he
can no longer ethically and
professionally fulfill his obligations
he said there has been an irreconcilable
breakdown in their professional
relationship which he now characterizes
as adversarial Greenspan made a similar
application last week at a court in
Winnipeg where niggard also faces sexual
assault related charges the judge urged
nyard to find a new lawyer quickly so
sentencing can proceed the 82-year-old
was found guilty of four counts of
sexual assault in Toronto in in
November there has been a rare
disclosure of medical details from
Britain's royal family the palace says
Kate Middleton Princess of Wales had
planned abdominal surgery surgery
yesterday and will be hospitalized for
up to two weeks Kensington Palace says
the surgery was successful but didn't
say what it was for a spokesperson later
described the condition as non-cancerous
she's not expected to return to public
duties until after
Easter and Buckingham Palace has
announced King Charles requires
treatment for an enlarged prostate the
75-year-old will be admitted to hospital
next week the palace usually keeps
things like this secret but says the
king wanted to share his diagnosis to
encourage others who may have symptoms
to get checked his public engagements
will be postponed as he
recovers war of words ahead how Hamas
and Israel's conflict goes beyond the
[Music]
battlefield Israel's Siege on Gaza and
the surprise attack by Hamas on Southern
Israel have been covered by media from
around the world there has been both a
flood of information and limits put on
it both the Israeli government and Hamas
are attempting to control the narrative
and influence public opinion foreign
journalists including Israelis cannot
get into Gaza and so the news from there
comes either from the few local
journalists still able to function in
Gaza or from the Israeli Army tonight
Danielle hamam Jin looks at the
information
War
in any War the truth is often a casualty
with the borders sealed the Foreign
Press hasn't been allowed into Gaza
other than with the Israeli
military and the images coming out are
thanks to local journalists who have
risked and lost their
lives tells us he believes Israel wants
to keep journalists away so they don't
cover what's happening his family was
killed in air
strikes yet for all their sacrifice few
Israelis across the border are exposed
to the full scope of the war in Gaza I
think it's the most shameful moment of
Israeli media ever Gideon Levy is a
veteran Israeli journalist and safe to
say disliked if not despised by many
here but I was present in Israeli TV and
today they called me and said at least
until the end of the war we cannot have
you
because both the panelists and the
viewers cannot sit with you cannot
listen to you I don't want to believes
his country had the right to retaliate
after October 7th but crossed the line
when he says women and children were
killed in masses it's really unheard of
because an average
Israeli so much less than an average
Canadian about what's going on on his
behalf half 1 hour away from his home in
Gaza that the world is seeing more
suffering out of Gaza than its own
Waring neighbor is for some entirely
Justified it will raise a lot of
question and the situation will be more
questionable for the people who are
serving right now in haa should we do
this and should we not showing what's
happening in Gaza would be too divisive
is what you're saying at a time when
there should be Unity yeah
absolutely for those in the West Bank
the plight of fellow Palestinians in
Gaza is always there on screen and in
conversation October 7th is already a
distant memory and many believe the
truth about that day has yet to come out
there is a reluctance here to speak
honestly about this topic on camera
mostly for security reasons but I asked
a few of them what they thought about
October 7th and the answer is always the
same they refused to believe Hamas could
ever kill women and
children in fact it's the majority of
Palestinians who think that according to
a recent public opinion poll 85% of
people in the West Bank in Gaza said
they have not seen videos showing
atrocities committed by Hamas on that
day there were killings yes but who
killed them I'm not
sure for many the thinking here goes if
the Israeli government said it then it's
unlikely to be
true Danielle hamam Jin Global News
Jerusalem what's down there next why
Canadian researchers are establishing an
underwater observatory in
[Music]
Antarctica some big news for Canadian
basketball fans the Toronto Raptors are
trading star player Pascal cakam the
Raptors veteran from Cameroon is being
sent to the Indiana Pacers as part of a
trade deal he was the last remaining
member of the roster that in 2019 won
Toronto's first NBA championship sakam
is also a two-time NBA Allstar well
across Canada and in the Arctic the
University of Victoria operates a
network of subsea stations to study the
waters around this country and now it
has a new underwater observatory in one
of the most remote regions of the world
the seafloor of Antarctica it's a
partnership with the Spanish Antarctic
station Juan Carlos I on the south
Shetland Islands in archipelago just off
the continent Mike Armstrong explains
what they're hoping to
find Spanish researchers weren't
supposed to deploy this Canadian
underwater Observatory for weeks instead
it was towed out and deployed on the
seafloor Tuesday weeks early the Spanish
team says when the weather cooperates
it's in Antarctica you take advantage of
it you need to work with good weather so
when we have a window of good conditions
we always take these benefits the
operation went off without a hitch
within hours the device was beaming
information back to Canada in fact
before Canadian researchers were even
looking for it all of the sensors are
delivering data in almost real time Kate
Moran is the head of ocean networks
Canada it's a research facility out of
the University of Victoria now the onc
has more than 12, th ocean sensors
around Canada's West Coast and the north
but is for the first time looking South
Spain operates two facilities in
Antarctica but only in the warmer months
from December to March it wanted to
monitor water and to do it year around
when they saw that we were doing these
kind of observations in the Arctic they
wanted to see them done in the Antarctic
as well the first part of the project
installed was this device dropped into
the water only about a kilometer from
the Spanish station
The Observatory is about 3 m tall and
sits on the sea Flor at a depth of about
25 M it's connected by a subseed cable
to a boy on Shore about 200 M away that
boy is then transmitting data by
satellite every 30 minutes it's really
understanding the the actual
characteristic of the ocean how much
oxygen is the ocean what's the
temperature what's the salinity what are
the nutrients the data is meant to help
researchers monitor how climate change
is affected Antarctica and hopefully
lead to Solutions there is a second part
of the project two Canadian floats that
will monitor the surface of the water
are set to be launched in a few weeks
that will of course be weather
permitting by Armstrong Global
News and that is global national for
this Wednesday I'm Donna freezen
tonight's your Canada is Emerald Lake in
Yoho National Park British Columbia
Picture Perfect scene we'd love to see
your Canada please email it to viewers
at global national.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye